In this video we will try to do
rational function graph.
A rational function is simply a function that
there are expressions in the numerator and the denominator.
There is a multi-faceted numerator. Let's see we have x ^ 2,
and one more in the denominator,
x ^ 2-16.
It is clear that we can make the chart by simply finding it
several points and join them.
That would be the special graphics calculator.
But we want before we try with
specific points, first to understand
the main structure of this chart.
We want to find out what happens when x happens
very, very large, or a lot
negative, negative.
If we look different, I want to know
what happens when the magnitude of x or the absolute value of x
it becomes really great
the infinity approaches.
When the magnitude of x approaches infinity.
In other words, when we go a long way
in the positive or negative direction,
what will happen to the value of
this feature?
Let's get the calculator out.
We will not use his graphics yet, he will only
try some values.
What happens when x is equal to 10?
Will be the same as when x is -10,
because, picking up a square -10,
we'll get 100, just like 10.
Similarly, -10 per square will give us
same as plus 10.
So it does not matter if we move into a very positive one
or strongly negative direction, whether we are approaching the positive one
or negative infinity, we reach the same thing,
because we raise square values.
Let's see some specific values.
If it takes 10 per square on 10 per square
minus 16, I get 1.19.
What if x is a little bigger?
We saw 10.
What will happen when x is 100?
We have 100 per square minus 16.
I'm getting closer to 1.
When x was 10, y was 1.19.
When x is 100, 100 per square minus 100 per
a square minus 16 gives us y = 1.0016.
Let's try 1000 now, just to see.
1000 per square divided by 1000 per square minus 16.
We are even closer to 1.
So while x increases,
y is getting closer to 1.
That would be true with -10,
because -10 per square on -10 per square minus 16
will give the same answer.
Because the negative numbers become positive,
when we pick them up in a square.
Here we will get the same as
at 10 per square.
Whether x becomes very large or very small,
we will approach y = 1.
If you want, you can try one million
you will get a number that is even closer to 1.
So, when the value of x approaches infinity, the absolute value of x
or the distance from the coordinate start approaches the infinity,
then y is close to 1.
Or you can imagine it in another way - the graph of the function
will approach the line y = 1.
Let me draw the rights y = 1.
I'll make a broken line because it's not
the graph of our function, but the right to which
the function is approaching.
Here's the graph of y = 1.
Here we have the idea of ​​a feature or graph of a function,
which comes close to a certain right, but never reaches it.
Graphics will increasingly approach those rights,
to y = 1 in this direction,
but will never reach it.
The distance to this y = 1 will tend to 0,
but he will never get there.
This right to which the chart is approaching,
is called asymptote.
This will become even clearer when
I draw the graph of the function itself.
We're going to work up here.
And since the rights are horizontal,
we call it a horizontal asymptote
Next to it is the graph when we go far
in the positive or negative direction.
Let's see other interesting facts about
this is the function.
He may have the impression,
that this is a difference from squares.
This is x ^ 2 minus 4 per square.
So we can present this as x ^ 2 on (x + 4) by (x - 4).
What will happen here as x approaches
to plus or minus 4?
First try with the following values.
If x is equal to 4, what will happen?
This expression here will
is equal to 0.
We will divide by 0.
But it is not possible!
Similarly, if x is minus 4,
we will have a division of 0.
This expression here will be 0.
We can not do that again.
We can conclude that the function is undefined
at x equal to plus or minus 4.
x can not accept these values ​​because
in both cases we will have a division of 0.
What happens when x approaches those values?
What happens when x approaches -4?
Let's try, just like that.
Let's say it's coming from the negative direction.
Let's see what the calculator says.
Let's say we come from the negative direction.
Let's start with -4.1.
If we have minus 4.1 per square divided by
-4.1 per square, minus 16, what will we get?
We have 20.75
So we get this number.
Let's see what happens if we get closer
to minus 4.
We're even closer to -4.
Let's have 4.11 instead of 4.1.
Here I put 4.01
and see what happens.
Now it's 200, that's the values
are increased.
Now let's try with 4,001.
and let's see what happens again.
Oops, that's not what I was trying to do.
I wanted to do this.
So, let's try.
Something is not happening to me.
Let's see.
So instead of the previous 4.01 I want to try 4,001
and here it is, minus 4.001.
And what happens?
It was 2000.
The closer we approach -4 in the negative direction,
we reach ever larger (even huge) numbers.
Try if you want with 4.0000001,
we will be getting bigger and bigger chips.
Perhaps it would be something like 20,000.
And then, we can put another zero here, and so on.
The closer we go, the bigger
numbers are obtained.
We can say that when x is approaching minus 4,
y is approaching infinity.
It takes an ever higher value.
But we can never reach the x = 4 itself.
It is indefinite.
He would make our denominator here 0.
We see that x has never been
exactly equal to -4.
Let's see x is equal to 1, 2, 3, 4.
We can never reach just to x = -4.
Let me draw x = -4 as a broken line,
right here.
This is x equal to -4.
We can never reach this line, but as we approach it
on the negative side - we have 4.1, then 4.01, etc.,
we are getting higher values.
We know that when we move left and
we reach increasingly high values ​​of x,
y is approaching 1.
You have a general idea of ​​what it will look like
this part of the chart.
That part of the chart will
it looks like this.
When x reaches ever more negative values,
y is getting closer to 1, and when x approaches -4
from the negative direction, u is approaching more and more
to infinity.
y is getting bigger and bigger,
let's just say it.
When x is -4, just as at x = 4,
the point on the graph will be undefined.
Let me draw this here.
1, 2, 3, 4
right here
x is equal to 4.
And once again, what happens when we approach x = 4,
to say in the positive direction?
What Happens When x Approaches 4
on the positive side?
This is like trying with x = 4,01 or
at 4,001 or at 4,0001 ...
So, we're just coming to
x equal to 4.
These are the same values ​​we have calculated
of the calculator, but with
a reverse sign, right?
And we actually noticed that with this feature,
the negative numbers are raised to a square so
that no matter if we get positive or negative numbers,
the answer will be the same.
This graph is symmetrical.
Having x = -5 is the same,
having x = 5.
x = -10 is the same as
at x = 10.
We will reach the same answer.
If you want, you can test this with your calculator.
If you test these values, you will see that when we get closer
up to 4, we get bigger numbers.
Same numbers as here.
Here's the graph - as we approach 4,
we get ever higher values ​​of y.
And here, when x increases,
as we have seen, we have these horizontal asymptotes
y is approaching 1.
And as we have called this horizontal asympto, these
values ​​- you can even see the corresponding vertical lines:
x = -4 and x = 4 - we call this
vertical asymptotes.
I will repeat again that these asymptotics are right,
to which the graph of the function is approaching, but never reached.
Here's what's happening here.
We can think of what's happening
with the graph of the function here inside.
There are several ways to imagine this.
You can say: What happens when x is approaching
4 from the negative direction?
Let's try this from the negative direction.
What if we take 3.9 per square divided by 3.9 per square minus 16?
We get minus 19.25.
What if we get 3.99?
Let me put another '9' to it
gets even closer to 4,
this time we are approaching 4 on the left side.
We put another 9 here.
And we have an even more negative number.
Let's just make one more attempt.
With a number even closer than the previous one.
Let's be 3,999.
Even closer to 4.
It is becoming more and more negative.
The same would be true with a minus 3.9.
-3,99 or -3,999 because when we raise a square,
positive and negative values ​​give the same result.
Less than 1 per square is plus 1.
When we get closer to 4 (we take 3.9, 3.99) we get
we get ever more negative numbers.
We clone to minus infinity.
Let me draw this here.
Just do not touch the asymptote. When we are coming from
this direction, our values ​​are getting smaller
and the graph is something like that.
As we approach the left, we get
ever smaller numbers.
The same will happen as we approach
to -4 right, right?
When we have 3.9, 3.99, 3.999, the values
we are falling.
The graphics will look like this.
And saga, when we have an idea of ​​what the graph looks like,
it is appropriate to put it
several specific points.
The easiest thing is - what do we have when x is equal to 0?
We have 0 per square on 0 minus 16.
When x is equal to 0, we will have 0
on minus 16, which is 0.
So, the point (0; 0) lies on the curve.
We can try with other things, but the common one
shape of our chart
it will be here.
You can add more points if you are interested
what will the curve between these points,
but we already have the overall structure.
We also found a lot of values ​​using the calculator.
I did all this because I wanted to explain
exactly why values ​​are getting lower.
And thinking about it all makes sense.
As we approach,
say up to 4,
in both directions, it will give us
an ever lesser number,
because this is the difference between x and 4.
So, it becomes a lesser number.
Then we take 1 on this, right?
We can see this as a square x on x + 4
or 1 on x - 4.
If this gets us less, this whole value
on a very small number is a very large number.
So, as you can imagine, values ​​will increase
and depending on whether they are approaching positive
or negative direction, that is, depending on whether this is a lot
a less negative or very small positive number,
this will turn our mark.
However, in both ways we are getting very big
absolute value in negative direction because
the difference between x and 4 on this side
is negative, is not it?
3.9 minus 4 is -0.1.
Let's take the opposite of what is 10.
So here we get negative numbers.
When we take the opposite, we will get a lot
big negative numbers.
I want you to understand the logic.
Usually the way to draw
This type of graphics is the first you find
horizontal asymptotes.
What happens when the value of x is high
big, so with very positive or
very negative values?
You can try a calculator if you wish.
You will literally get an answer if you try
million or billions.
But you can also consider this in the following way - when x
becomes very large, these values ​​are rising
much faster - this article is simple
constant
and it does not matter anymore.
If it's one million and that's one million,
who is interested in this 16?
When x is very large, y is
approximately x per square on x per square.
These two articles matter.
You no longer need to think about it 16.
And this is equal to 1 - exactly
like when we used very large numbers.
For similar tasks where you have the same coefficient
equally in numerator and denominator,
look at the coefficient of these members.
In this case, our odds are 1 and 1.
So our horizontal asymptote will be 1 divided by 1, or
y equal to 1.
If it was 2x 2 on (x ^ 2 -16),
our asymptotic would have been y = 2.
We were going to get closer to that right here above.
And if we had -2, our horizontal asymptote
would have been y = -2.
Here's how we find horizontal asymptotes when
we have the same degree in the numerator
and in the denominator.
If the denominator is to a greater extent,
it will grow faster than the numerator
and the asymptote will be 0.
Later I will show you an example.
And, logically, if the numerator is of a higher degree
by the denominator, it will increase much faster
by the denominator, and we will not have any asymptotes.
Value will simply grow or it will happen
increasingly negative.
This is the case with all the many,
which we have seen.
We can also imagine them as 1
In this case we do not have a horizontal asymptote.
And vertical asymptotes are found to be simple
we decompose the denominator
and find out when it would be equal to 0.
These are the points where the graph is undefined.
I'll show you later that there are specials
cases where we do not have vertical asymptotes.
But I will not confuse you with that for now
We will see these special cases in some other video.
In general, if we break down the denominator members
they are not shortened by anything from the numerator, then
we're dealing with a vertical asymptote.
If I had x - 4 here above, if my numerator was
x ^ 2 on (x - 4), this would be shortened
and the expression would be simplified.
But the expression would remain undetermined for 4 equal to 4 because
we would have 0 in the denominator.
But since (x - 4) is shortened by (x - 4) in the numerator,
we would have a vertical asymptote
We will go back to that some other time.
But that was not the case.
So the basic rule for determining vertical asymptotes is:
decompose the denominator, find out when it is 0,
and if no member is abridged
with no member of the numerator,
these values ​​are our vertical asymptotes.
And to find the behavior of values ​​in
asymptotes, we can try with some points.
We can take some values ​​of x and
to find what y will be.
To make sure our answer is correct,
let's make the graph of our rational function.
Let me draw it.
y = x ^ 2 divided by x ^ 2-16.
Let's see what happens.
I do not have the set of function values.
Let me write the set of function values.
The minimum value for x,
let's say it is -10.
And the maximum value I want is x = 10.
Scale of x - 1.
I want a minimum value of y to be -10,
and the maximum value of y is 10.
The scale of y is 1.
Let me draw this.
Here.
Look at this.
Just like our drawing.
We have asymptotes - when x becomes very large or very small,
this asymptote is y = 1.
We have a vertical asymptote.
The calculator includes it because it simply links the points,
but the asymptote would not really be
part of the graph.
When we approach 4 of 0, we can say that
we are 'super' negative.
When we reach -4 out of 0, we also become super negative.
Because in both situations when we are approaching 4
on this side, this article will be negative.
When we get close to -4 on this side, this one
Article here will be positive,
but this will be negative.
Negatively positive it always gives a negative number.
In both cases, we move to a negative infinity.
And when x approaches infinity, that
here is the asymptote.
I hope you were all interesting.